read the inspector-general michael a
horror was concluded that former FBI
deputy director Andrew McCabe lied four
times three times under oath about his
role confirming the existence of the
FBI's Clinton Foundation investigation
just two weeks before the presidential
election according to Horowitz McCabe
was angered by a Wall Street Journal
article suggesting he had a conflict
because his wife received more than
$600,000 from Democrats for 2015
Virginia State Senate race that she lost
McCabe authorized FBI Boyer Lisa Paige
and the FBI's Public Affairs chief
Michael Courtin to discuss issues
related to the Clinton Foundation
investigation including a dramatic phone
call between McCabe and a senior Justice
Department official some of the key
evidence in this case comes from text
messages between page and McCabe McCabe
seniority gave him the authority to
release information to the media if
certain conditions were met but the
Inspector General found McCabe active
for personal rather than professional
reasons
reading McCabe's decision to confirm the
existence of the Clinton Foundation
investigation through an anonymously
sourced quote recounting the content of
a phone call with a senior department
official in a manner designed to advance
his personal interests at the expense of
department leadership was clearly not
within the public interest exception
this afternoon President Trump tweeted
McCabe lied multiple times the McCabe
was controlled by his boss director
Comey and he claimed there is no
daylight between the two men the White
House press secretary put it this way I
haven't seen the full report but it
sounds like two peas in the pod with
McCabe and Comey
McCabe was fired and disgraced for
misconduct and lying about it in a
statement McCabe's attorney said the
termination of mr. McCabe was completely
unjustified and the rush to fire him at
the goading of the president was
unworthy of the great traditions of the
Department of Justice he footnote in the
report says McCabe argued his account
was more credible than commis because
his old boss wanted to distance himself
from media leaks
McCabe said he believed the Inspector
General was also investigating Comey as
a leaker Brett Catherine thank you more
on all of this with the panel